[音楽]
ガチャに出て
我慢されなんがちゃに
グテオンリー
ナンマンサラダイ
ガチャ
入れてやんぴーさんがされ何ガチャに3
段差に
[音楽]
飛び降り
仏壇皿に
[音楽]
扉
さまにかかれ
らに
世界
様々な
[音楽]
仕方がさまに
ならない
世界に
[音楽]
仕方がさまに
がいる間に
近場だんさまで
闇
武装だ
寺に
世界から
サマリア見せる
交え玉だったな
車に
仕方が
さまに
すらねー
[音楽]
慈悲のメッセいたします
私は
幸せでありますように
私の
[音楽]
悩み苦しみが
無くなりますように
私の
願い事が
叶え
られますよように
私に
悟りの
光があら
れ
ますように
私は
幸せでありますよ
[音楽]
私は
幸せにありますように
幸せになりますよ
私は幸せでありますようにと繰り返し何し
ます
私の
すべて
沈めが
幸せでありますように
私の
親しい
生命の
[音楽]
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますよ
私の教えたし
生命の
[音楽]
願い事が
叶えられますように
私の
親し
責めにも
悟りの
怒りが
あられますでは
[音楽]
生命が
幸せでありますように
私の
親しい
生命が
幸せでありますよ
私の
親しい
生命が
幸せであります
ように
親しい生命が幸せになりますようにと
繰り返し祈ります
ものが
幸せでありますよに
生きとしてるものの
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
生きとしてるものの
願い事が
叶える
ように
ものにも
悟りの
光が
現れますように
生きたしてるものが
幸せでありますように
愛してるものが
生きとしているものが
幸せでありますように
ものが幸せになりますようにと念じます
ものが
幸せでありますね
[音楽]
生きとしているものが
幸せでありますように
生きたしてるものが
はいありがとうございます
ではよろしくお願いします
今日の
飽和会に
参加させて皆様方にまぁ心から感謝いたし
ます
散歩で出かけるとかし
特に私のような年齢の人は出かけたくない
んだけど
今日のテーマはこの
リセプションというのは日本
語簡単にこの騙しということにしています
けど
リセプションというともっと意味が
敷地がいます何か
自称で漢字を広げ
拾ったんだけど
読めないんですこれは
騙し騙される人生を
解析していますということでね
でこの
テーマの方はこうねあの
こういう名前出している方々のお
布施で
実現できましたこと
心から感謝いたします
藤本力様
正幸さん
頼む力士さん
[音楽]
前田真理子さんという
病名の
方々ですはいそれも
仏教活動にいろいろ
多大な協力をして
助けてくれる方々でございます
でまぁお布施の中でね一番
極力の高い
拳でありまして
でお布施と大体こんな物質の
移動だけですけど
[音楽]
我々生きている人々には
物質は
所有することはできません
ですから
移動は可能でしょうし
だから皆様
この矛盾した方々は
自分たちの
持っているお金をねまあ
会場費として
お治めたことでそれは物質異動だけなん
ですねしかし
心の中に起こる変化が
単純なものじゃないんです
どんな目的で
この自分にも使える物質
を別なところに移動させるのかと
いうことで
ブッダの真理をね
たくさんの方々
知って
汚れた心
清らかにしてほしいとね
罪深い心をね
善に
満たしてほしいという
希望なのでそのすべての人類を
意識死んだことになります
具体的には
それからこの人には
自分の力で
幸福の
扉を開けないんです
別に外から鍵かけているわけじゃないんだ
けどね
この
幸福の扉の一つの
火山ですよ
このパズル受けないんですね
だから
ブッダの話を聞くことでこのパズルの解き
方順番で
教えてあげているんですその
順番で自分が動けば
結局弦の
幸福の
致している
扉が開きます
開きます
はい
教える方々の
幸福がありますように
幸福になりますように素材いたします
に入ります
今日はできるだけ短くしゃべりたいと
思っても一応あの
データを調べてみたんですねあまり仏典の
はこうそれほど出してないんだけど
仏教の世界は
すごい膨大な
知恵のことをね
行ってしまいますからね
俗世間はそうじゃないんですね
ほんの場所かなことを言うためには
膨大なる研究するんですね
だからこの
騙しではなくてリセプションという世界ね
まあそれも騙しですからね
結局は
これはね
古代文明の時代からも人間が
やられてきて人間がやったよりも人間が
やられていたんです
騙されていたんです
今我々は支配している西洋文化は
完璧な嘘の考えの上で成り立っているん
です
で
神がジギジギ
喋ったという
言っているこの
あんなのは特にあのもう
節が一体
物語が
目覚めての偉人の物語なんですね
そういう人々やられたことはこいつは
偉そうに
好き勝手に
しながら
喋ったそうでそれはどの人々は書いたんだ
から
自分に好きなように
編集しちゃって
誠実さの作って宗教システム作って
極限に
差別する目的で人を搾取する目的で
書いているんです
だからこの
差別することを作成すること
を支えてないテキストを全部
削除して
捨てちゃったんです
それは
後で色々なところで見つかってね
結構ありますね昔私も
愛しく立つ読んでみたんですけどね
すごい審判の話がね
人もいなかったしね
昔この
イエスがいた時代より
結構前は
いたんですけどその人は1億円で
黒人なんです
その人は立派な方でね
十字架で殺されたこともなかったし
その人は確かにデータあるみたいんですね
あのエジプトで
密室視線というまあそれ
心
を育てる方法なんでそれから
チケットに行って
それからまた
色々どうやって人の病気治せますかとかね
自分の心の
力でね
言うことでこの意識を学んでいたんですが
聖書では殺す殺す殺すしかないんですね
はいそういうことでこの私はまたたくさん
いろんなところ見たらもう
会話はもう
魂で成り立っている
ということで
めんどくさいんだから簡単にしたんです
けども
し頭がちょっとおかしくなったら喋るかも
しれません
でだからすごいシンプルで第1ステップ1
で騙されたくないね
ずっと
古代文明から騙されてきたんだけど
騙されてしまうのはもう
遺伝子に記録しているんです
この方も教えてがねあの
すごい
原始人としていた時はまあほとんど動物
すれ違い方でそれから何かもう遺伝子改良
させちゃってね
突然文明
文化を作ったりして
爆発して手にこの
脳みそが
開発しちゃったんですね
育てたんだけど
脳みそをどうやって
使うのかというところはまあ
学ぶ
先にああいう文明がすごい消えちゃったん
ですねまぁ
インド文明見たらもう
昔
膨大な能力持っていたんです
突然全て消えちゃったんです
遺伝子改良したことやらこの
なんかわからない
今もやってますけどこの
乱視に精子をね
自分
選んだ青春を入れて
人間作ると最後というものを作るんだって
ねそういう
インドの南インドのこの
ヒンドゥテンポの中でね
すごい昔作ったお
寺ですけど
ちゃんと書いている
んでしょう
面白いことはインドにもそういう古代の
文明の歴史があってがなくなっちゃった
隣のスリランカと島にもありまして
無くなっちゃった
くなって今の人間
本も作品たちが
世界を支配することになってしまったん
ですその時はもうトクンと特に
リセプションというのは
入れてあるんです
で人間がやっぱりこの
脳をどうやって返すのかとわからないん
ですね
だから色々
言葉を勉強したり調べたりして
科学をね
科学を発展したり
ですねだから科学世界見ただけでも
教会の教えに逆らわなくちゃあかん
でしょう
食事代の人々も殺されちゃったんだからね
何のことなく
心を
次元変えて育ちられますよと言った
ギリシャ人が
ベロを引っ張ってそれを切って1週間も何
も食べさせないで
逮捕しておいてそれから逆さまにして
ビルを引っ張って
切って
それから火をつけて
焼いちゃったんです
これ痛いなる
教会があるんです
神父さんたちが
そこで皆様うまくしておけになっている
でしょうだからね
平和の
王子様やとかに
違う湧いてきますその時はね
平和のおじさま
どれほど太いところしたのかと
漢文に
それから
奴隷制度
神の言葉として
正当化しているんです
事実
そんなバカがいなかったんだからいい別に
いいんだけど
新約聖書で
イエスがこう言ったとね
どれ
解放しなさいじゃなくてどれだったら正直
で素直でマスターに
従って
仕事するべきやと
まぁそういうところも騙されていてそれで
科学者は命かけて
香川研究したんですね地球が丸い
だから
わかるでしょうこの騙す意識よりは
それ騙されたくないということは個人が
持っている素直な気持ちなんです
思っているだけで
何もやってないね
だからこの
我々今は素晴らしい天才だこれ
アインシュタインなら
入店に浸っても
基本的な
発見しましたし
アインシュタインはもっと
未だにすごい使っているね法則いくつか
発見しましたし
相対
理論ですね
そういう人々のこと
すごいというだけで
その人々はやっぱり頑張ったんですよ
騙されたくはないということ
お前言っても私は自分で調べますよと
まぁそういうことで
どんな人間も騙されたくないということを
持っているんですで仏教も
この
破ってください
そうするとあなたは
自分になります
フリーダムという
仏教は解脱という気持ちを教えていてまぁ
現代この
死
哲学者
はね
新しい時代の人々はあまり
無神教でもないんだけど自分に適した宗教
作っているんですね
そういう人々はヒンドゥー教で言っている
このユニバーサル観察というこの
宇宙的な一つの心があるんだよという
ところで
個人の心もその一部で
だからそここの
邪魔者全部
切ってそこ一緒になれば
いいんじゃないかなという考え持ってい
ますねそれは
現代の若い人々の
という言葉にしているんですね
聞いてみたらなんか
だらしない単語で聞こえますけど裏は
かなり
かなり優れた
哲学を持っているんです
でIamGOというのはヒント教でもね
あの
昔
語られていたことなんですお疲れ様はこれ
はダメやと
その執着も捨てなさいと
そちらがあなたやられますと
輸入する感謝します
例えばもっと俗っぽい例えば例えば水滴が
あります
可哀想一匹のミスだから
でも地球の水は
海にありますからね
そこは大元ですね
言ってから水を
あんたちっぽけでかわいそうで
くたくていじめられているんだからじゃあ
海に戻して
戻りなさいと戻してあげる
だったら自由自在になるのかと
海でならないね
海の法則にやられます
だから仏教はこれはもう解脱
本当の自由じゃないんだと
しかし
クロス
になったような気がする
気持ちでそれを飛ばして
逃すというところに
なりなさいというのは仏教のせいなんです
ね
はい
騙されたくないというところはどんな人間
の
心にもあるものです
でこれは我々一般的に考える程度の
品のない言葉じゃないんです
心の心底
騙されたくないという気持ちがあるんです
ね
そこで何で騙されたくないといえば自分も
守りたいんですね
しかし他人がどのような手口を使うのかと
わからないそれを特別に勉強もしないそこ
で
我々の問題があるんです
自分をどのような手口で騙しているのかと
分からないんですね
わかったら騙されないでしょうに
わかってないからこそ騙されるんですね
そこで騙されたと次の騙されない限り
他人の手口は分からないだから騙されたと
気づいたところで
手口は知っています
まぁ同じ手首でもう二度と騙されないんだ
けど
別れ
はね
でももっと俗っぽく日本の社会見ると私が
もうずっと長い間ねもう40年くらい日本
にいたんだから
同じ
手口で騙されるまた5年経ったらまた同じ
手口でもされると
これは私にとってはすごく腹が立つんです
ねなんだこれやと
騙してもいいんだけど
手口ぐらい変えなさいよと
そこで
腹が立っているのは騙す側じゃないんです
騙される側に怒っているんです
何でちょっと1年2年前で同じことをやっ
たやってやられちゃったんだから
あんた同じことなんで
だからそれで
腹が立ったというただの文学的な
怒ったわけじゃないんだけど
私はそれで困るんですよなぜなら私は仏教
を教えているんだからあの
根本的な
資格ないんですね
[拍手]
これはギリシャ語で
講演するような感じになっちゃうと
誰もわからないで
根本的な能力ないんだけどギリシャ語勉強
してないんだから
例えば日本語で喋ってますけど
日本語のような言語で私は
喋ってますけど
皆様は日本語知っているんだから
資格持っているんですね
だから理解その気になれば理解できます
悪口じゃないんですよ人の話聞いても
理解するか理解しないかということは人の
自由だからね
騙されているのに死ぬまで気づかないこと
もあります
死んでから気づいたともう遅いんですね
例えば人が死んじゃったら
見出さんが来て
魂を
持っていて
ごく
速度なんとかのところで
金の
蓮の花でしたっけ
そちらで
自分
特養な花があってこれ原理でできています
けど
座っていると
極楽堂だからねものすごい
いいところですね
もしなかったらどうする
あれは
完璧騙した言葉
騙す言葉だったらどうする
だからそうやって死ぬまで
騙されているかとわからない
ものもあるんですね
こんなのは仏教では至って単純
立証できんだったら嘘それだけで
五分五分はダメやと
例えば極楽とあるかもしれませんないかも
しれませんでしょう
真ん中ないでしょう
極楽とあるある
だから自業自分がGoogleに行くか
行かないどちらかでしょうでも行くために
は何だらかんだらなんだらかんだら時間
ですね
それ時点でお釈迦様は
相手は嘘を言っているんだと
事実は確率はないし
そういうのは簡単です
次はこの
自分に何か
守るこれ
漢字が違うんですね
[音楽]
自分何か守るものがあるとき自分に必要な
ものがあるとき
騙されてそれが他人の手に入るのは嫌なん
ですね
だから騙されるためにこれを条件にこれ私
の大事なものという何か
ないと
自分には冷静とるものは何もないんだっ
たら
騙されないんです
これでハンドパワーでガンガンのガン治り
ますよと言った途端走るでしょう
夢やってますよ
癌治した人は一人もいないと思いますけど
ハンドパワーで
利益という言葉を使ってこれちょっと
巧みに騙されているんですねそれであの
インド人も
ヨーロッパ人もこの
同じ日本語の単語で英語でもレイキ
みんなフル素晴らしい考えやと
思っているんだけど私だとハンドパワーと
別に大切
に思いますけどね
ただ騙したいだけ
それで人っていうのは自分が病気になる
自分の身体が
自分の身体と思っているでしょう
病気治してほしいと思っているでしょう
死にたくないと思っているでしょう
だからハンド側に走っちゃいますよ
だったら理想かというしハンドパワーで
ガン治るならば
金額いくらぐらいですかとそれでまあ
そこまだ騙しこれ宗教だからね
金額言いませんよと
でもは遺産がこの間
美白万も払いますし
有名な
奥さんが
[音楽]
1000万も寄付しましたしいろいろ情報
を上げるんです
私が若い人だったら首を絞めるんですよ
その人の
だってこちらお金あげればいいかという
ことを決めるためにデータ取っている
でしょうその時騙し働いてくるんです
五千円ではダメやっていることでしょう
知っているの
何でやらないんですかねじゃあ
ガン治してあげますしかし
ハンドパワー上げる
なんとかするというためにもう100万も
必要だと
しかしあなたの病気治らなかったら
全額
払い戻しますよ
行った方が
理性的で
騙しないでしょう
そこで払い戻しはないんです
それでアホな連中は後でギャグ
言ったりして
裁判もかけたりして
で
裁判例えば
自分が喜んであげたものをまた取り戻す
法律じゃないんです
だから国会でもそういう問題になってくる
と
ハチャメチャ困るんです
だからこの
至る所でそういう風に騙しが働いてだから
今出した例でもわかりますねやっぱり
どんな人でも
自分の体に
頑張って欲しくないんですね
私は今いろいろ身体がすごく酷く良くなっ
てますけど
別にない方がいいとはね
言えるでしょうに
それであなた体はまた再び元に戻してあげ
ますよと
ハンドパワー出てたら
先にやってくださいそれからお金なります
よと私なら言いますが言ったって意味が
ない私は法則世の中の宇宙のまで
知っているんだから皆さん
騙されませんしね
騙されてこの
子はないとは自分と自分
自分が所有するものを手放したくないと
いう意味にもなりますね
はい
次行きますそこで私は何となく言っている
ポイントは
仏教用語で言えば
執着ですね
私の金を騙しても
騙されて取り上げて欲しくない
私の家族を
相手を
誰かに取り
騙してもう
連れて帰るのは嫌なんです
という私のだから
執着を与えてますね
だから何で私は騙されたのかというと私に
執着だったからなんです
に行きます
騙すこと
これはあまり我々に関係ないんだけどね
個人
複数の人々
社会
国人類などに
騙す
相手は
拡大しては何か日本
自分で書いたんだけど自分ではあんまり
明確な文章になってないんですね
言いたかったのは
個人王を騙す
複数の人々ループを騙す
社会全体的に騙す
国を丸ごと騙す
人類を騙す
だから
話し始める前に私は言ったのは人類を黙っ
たところなんです
あらゆる聖書なんか持っていて
聖書類
結構あるでしょうに
一つもろくに書いてないでしょうに
支離滅裂で
それは
神はどんな
獣もいいんだけどで
神でかなり頭が
イカれている人ということだけは確かなん
です
まぁインドの経験では
文学作品としては
結構いい作品です
それで
せて学んだらこの言語を学ぶことには
ものすごく役に立ちます
あれで三振と言うんだけどとっても
古い
んですね
そこから世界的に
言葉が
広がったんです
だからレディースの大元になった言語も
あってそこをちょっと言語の
言葉の
進化
拡大
いろんな枝に分かれる
別れること
だと英語で
言うでしょうこれは
同じ
もちでしょうちょっと変わって
こちら
貸して
でまた
いきなり英語になってない予算する
旅をして
旅に出て
インドになっちゃってラテン語になっ
ちゃったりそれから
じわじわと英語でもなったりとかねだから
それなりの
変身がありますまぁそういうことを学ぶ
ためには
テキストを読むのは
すごくよろしいしまた
誰にでも勉強できるようにきめ細かく愛の
解説して
注釈を入れてもう
勉強勉強した
本体やるんだからね
しかし
内容はなんかこの
神を拝んでいるという
言葉なんですけど
神を先端するというね
その時点変なんですね
神と安らかす
力持ちだったら何であいつらを
褒め称えて
機嫌取らなくちゃあんですかね
でそれもあるしそこで神と言ってもこの
方々はあまり分かってないんだから
風雨
雷
太陽
などなどに
賛美歌を歌っているんですね
あの太陽に賛美歌を歌ってもいいんだけど
それは科学的に我々は太陽の力が出ている
んだということは科学的にも
我々は
世界していますからね
そんなこと知らなかったんだからね
そういうことで
人類騙すというね
言葉ありますよ
人間で生まれたらもう騙される
騙すことには
時間の関係もあります
要するに何かの手口で騙してもこれで
ずっと騙すということもないんですねまぁ
例えばね
簡単にバレる何年経ってから明らかになる
戦争だいたい
騙し続ける
歴史的に騙されるなどありますね
歴史的に騙されていても
後で新しいデータが出てくるとあれはそう
ではなかったと私は新しく
書き換え
例えば高校学的に高校学的にいろんなもの
を発掘したりしてあるいは
今まで見つからなかった古いテキストを
見つかっちゃってとかねそこをデータ分析
すると今まで
騙されたことはまぁちょっと
変えなくちゃいけないんだけど難しい
魂に入る可能性もあります
時間
経ったらバレるということはまあよくある
ことで日本では最近起きた何とかの出来事
の
おかげで
追っかけて言うんですかねそういう原因で
宗教は騙されるということはまた
表に
来たんですね
[音楽]
あれは事件が起きたからなんですねあの
事件が起きなかったらやられますよかなり
騙す側に利益があって
成り立つそれで
騙す
側には利益があるんです
で聖書を持ってきて神のことを持ってきて
もうそろそろ皆様も新宿やらいろんな
シビアとかねあるいは明治神宮とかね
歩いてみてください
棒にスピーカーつけて
みんな流していますよ
正規真っ直ぐ
来ますよと
もうそろそろ神が
地球にも
降りる日が近づいてますよと
悔い改めなかった連中はみんな永遠な地獄
に落ちますよと
イスラはあの連中は人々分からないのは
なんか神が来るということあまりいいこと
じゃないね
我々はたまに悪いことしても人は許して
あげるしね
まあいいやもうまぁかわいそうだからまあ
それ許してあげましょうと
人間より
立ちが悪いんですね
これを信じないレンジはみんなに永遠の
地獄に落とすぞと
永遠の地獄なんかあるわけでもないし
でそれで
神野郎が来ないしね
誰が儲かっているのかと
だってもうそろそろ来ますよともう来年期
まで終わって何回も聞いたことあるんだ
から私の原価のピンポンまで鳴らして大変
私も
本当に
物の見事にばかりしてやれるんです
自分でもここまで言う必要あるのかいと
ただもう脳みそがない
進化していない人間だからもうちょっと
優しく
喋った方がいいんじゃないかなと思いつつ
も
向こうは凶暴だからね
だから凶暴な言葉はいただくんです
そこでこの
騙す
人っていうの力ありますよ
騙される人は弱いでしょうだからこの逆
肉強食というね
法則ですねそちらにもあるのは
それで
騙す手口を
巧妙に発展させなくてはいけないんですね
それはやっているでしょう
はい
次にこの何で騙す
魂というリセプションというこれが人間の
中にあるんですかね
それは希望という病気なんです
人に希望願望を鍛えなどは
無数にあります
相当病気なんですそれで不安
不満を感じるんです
何で人間不安感じるのかとなんで不満
感じるんですかね
死ぬだけでしょうに
だから人間に何ができるか分かっている
でしょうに
それで不平本持ったという意味がない
それは希望
願望があるからなんです
だからこの
希望が叶えるように
異様な話に喜んで乗ります
だからダム人を騙すならばじゃあ教えて
あげますこれから言ってみよう頑張って
ください
相手の希望願望何なんでしょうかと
ちょっと匂ってみる
それに乗って話す
いたって心配です
例えばあるお母さんが若いお母さん女性が
もう自分の子供と
テニスないでもどこか行くとしましょう
行為で
それ誰かがこれ男に難しいんだけど誰かが
大体宗教の世界でもこのおばさんたち
でしょこれ騙しやっているのは
男性っていうのを
騙すよりは脅しですね
それで
ある
ばあちゃんが来てあぁ
可愛い
子供さんですね
幸せでして言っちゃったあのお母さんが
乗る
我が子は可愛い当たり前でしょうに
それからいくらこんなにも輝いている子供
っていうのはマネーでしょうとかね
私がびっくりしましたこのオーラにとかね
子供の
びっくりしました
やってみて
まんまと騙されますよ
このお子さんのオーラが
すごい真っ白くて
こんな
ボールを天皇陛下様にもないんだよ
乗ると言ったってももうこちらも何も乗り
ますよあのお母さんは
それからまあ
しっかり何か
悪霊とか何でもいいんですね何か
そこもかかっているんだからなかなかこの
力発揮できんやと
この勉強したらもうノベル賞取れるぐらい
の
能力持っていますけどこの何かちょっと
かかっているんだよと
影が
これ抜いてあげましょうと
その子供の
あれなんて言いますかこの
人生にかかっているこの影をね抜いて
あげるために
それからまぁこれこれ
でも
ですからこの騙すということはそんなに
心配なことで日本ではこれはこのセミナー
やってほしいいるんだからね
日本でもこの
抜群にこの400万
冊作れたという本当かは全部
騙し
の方法を教える本でしょう
で
上司に喋る
喋り方を
でもうあれはこれとかねまぁ
億万長者に一年で億万長者になる方法とか
ね
嘘でもないんですあの本書いた人が億万
長者になっているんだからね
本買って読んだ人が一度なってないよでも
騙されているんだからそれは言わない誰
騙す
側は
能動的に騙される側は自動的にこの
ドラマに
参加します
両方買わないとねそこで今お母さんの例
だったんだから騙された
お母さんが自動的
暗そうですかそうですか
喋りかけていたおばあさんがもう
能動的にこれでこれでこれこうやって
くださいこうやってくださいとかね
いうことでこのドラマが
起きます
この人間にある
希望に
仏教用語は
活性なんですね
割愛というものはあるんだろう心に
触れ合ったらあんた終わりやと
やられますよと
で割合は
単純な単語ですけど
結構
レアがある
話で一番
わかりやすいこと
私は言うのこの
生きていきたい死にたくないという
気持ち
は分かりやすい
レイヤーなんですね
この価値は生きていきたいということと
一緒に
感情が
割り込んできますね
どんな風に生きていきたいなとか何年も
生きていきたいのかとかね
どんな人間として生きていきたいのかとか
ねどうやって社会で
成功しさになるのかとかね
1500の感情が
絡んできて組んできて
活動します
だけでそんなに力ないんだけどいっぱい
感情を合わせて
すごい力になるんです
人に
勝つわい煩悩がある限り
騙す現象は存続します
だから人は運命的に
騙されます
魚は釣り餌作るんだからね
魚にはその
判断する能力ないんです
食えるもの見たらパクッと食うしかないん
です
これは賞味期限
考えていないんだから魚は
これは味の都会
社会に会社が名前言ってんだけど
味の素を会社ですか日本ハム会社で作った
製品ですかと
下がらない
目の前に
浮いているもの見たらパクッと食って
しまうんです
それがあるから
無理魚たちの学校で
目の前に
うろうろしているものは絶対こう流れと
いうこと教えたらどうなる
あれ食べたら癌になりますよと
健康な食べ物というのは追っかけてきて
いくものやと
教えたらまぁ
持っている人は
スピードボートに乗っていかなくちゃいけ
なくなっちゃうんです
はい
すでにまあもうさっさと仏教の世界にあり
ましょうこの騙すということはこの
我々は遺伝的に本能的に人間にあることで
今は私たちみんな
被害者気分に喋ってますけど
偉そうにね
加害者になってますよ
これは悪行為ですよ
だから悪行為というためには能動的に騙す
こと
しなくちゃいけないんですねされることが
まあある程度で悪行為なんですが
もう受動的だからね
自分に煩悩があったんだから
上に感情があったんだから
例えばなんかすごいバランドの
カバンが欲しいなぁとか思ったところで
光明に作った偽物を
安くてに入ったと
びっくりやと
彼は
30万円と
ある友達が
十分で売ってくれたと
喜んでいるんでしょうあの自分に何かの
バラの鞄が欲しいという
感情が希望があったからでそれを来たのは
後で
台湾の人旅人
旅行に行ったら
飲んだ1万人もならないんですね売って
ます
それで
キャラに立ったとね
だけどやっぱり
感情に乗ることはもう
悪行為なんですよ
字はわかりやすい
自分には
食べ物の好みがある
この日ばっかしパクパクで食べると
悪行為ですよ
健康が
悪くなりますからね
身体壊れますからね
脂っこいものはもう
すぐでたまらんやとでいつでも
油こういうもの食べちゃってそれでは
なくなっちゃって
血管が遅くなっちゃって心臓を起こったり
して
終わりですね人生は
もっと腹が立つのは私はもう小さいという
からも油大嫌いなんです
という私のコレクションのハチャメチャ
高いんです
で心臓の結果も遅くなっているんですこれ
腹が立たない
喜んでそこでたまらん人々には
しょうがないんですね
だから自分の
感情によって
負けることも
悪行為にした方が
よろしいんですなぜならば
後で
悪い結果になりますからね
だから騙されることも悪行為と言っても
構わないがあれを微妙だから
置いておいて
騙す行為は不幸にです
人と人が会うたびに
騙し騙される法則が働く恐る恐れがあり
ます
気をつけてください
人と人と会って喋ってると
知らんうちにだと遺伝子的に
入れているんだから
やっているでしょうだいたい今日はすごく
元気そうでとかね
違い関係が起こる
ので
悪行為です
意外関係の
再利用ってまた
感情の力によって悪行為の
差が成り立ちます
だからこのどれぐらい悪行為ですかという
とこれはまぁ
仏教の世界ではこの
砂糖と
言ってますからそれは
悪いことやとちょっと思い
レイヤーに入れてます仏教では
詐欺行為はね
悪の
リストの場合はこの重い
悪のレイヤーに
入れてあります
そこで
相手に
どれぐらい
被害
与えているのかと
例えば
我々昔
シンプルな人間だったらねまぁ
餌をちょっと置いておいてそちらに
罠を引っ掛けておく
そうすると野生の動物が開けて餌食べよう
と思っちゃうと
は何科かかっちゃう
だから
動物は
騙されたでしょう
同時に命もなくなりますね
だからそこで
殺生と騙す行為
悪声二つ
繋がっているんです
この騙すことで大罪
とっても10歳とっても思い罪を犯すこと
もできます
でこの麻原がそういう
騙し説法して
車輪まで作らせて
心を起こしちゃったんですね
時々この宗教世界でこの韓国でも一つ事件
を受けたしアメリカでは23回起きたし
集団自殺する
神様のところに行きましょうと
どこまで試されている
黙っているのかと
だから騙されている人はどこまで人間では
ないのかと人間になってない
身体持ったってもう
それで集団自殺したからといって
利益を得る人いないんですね
だからもう信じられない悪行為
10歳なんです
だってそれに自分の家族もと
入れちゃうし
親も入れちゃうしね
また
いろんな信仰宗教組織でこのお
祈りすれば
神は全知線の完全な存在だから神は
不完全な血管でのものは作りませんよと
だから祈っちゃえばこの白血病は
治りますよと
言って治療は
断って祈るはエネルギーはハチャメチャ
エネルギー
は死ぬ
死んでも親は
泣かない
やっぱり神様がうちのこう早く展開に
呼びたかったと
どこまで騙されてますかね
昔日本で大地震があってたくさん人々は胃
が良くしゃって亡くなっている
人が私にもなんかわからないんだけど出る
のかけてこの日本のお坊さんたちがこの
アビス様
もかいたんだから
亡くなった方々のところで
極限な幸福にいるんだから
悩まなくても嫌って言っちゃうとこの
家族が無くなった人々はそれですごくあの
話聞いて私は
落ち着きましたよと
で日本のお坊さん達が
騙す気持ちではなくて
線にで
人の
悲しみを無くしてあげたいと
自分の修行を通してね人を助けることを
修行だからこの場合どう助ければいいか
わからなくなっちゃって悩んでいるんだ
から
だから
迎えに来たんだよと
言って何とかそういった途端に頭に横切っ
た考えがお前のこと神様は嫌いですかねと
か
言わなかったんだけど
言えないしね
だからそちらで
矛盾があるんですね
お父さんあるいは私の息子は阿弥陀様に
迎えに来て
安倍様は連れて行っちゃって良かった
よかったとあなたは
泣いているでしょう
私のこと愛沢で嫌い
だから
連れていかない
だから私は
悪口言います私のこと嫌いになって
くださいと
迎えに来ない
で
まぁそれは日本語の言葉で嘘も方便やと
いう風な言葉を使ってそれは
チャラにしますけどねまあ
嘘は方便じゃない
嘘っていうのはバカが使う
騙しなんです
例えば
家族の誰か誰か亡くなっちゃって落ち込ん
で泣いている人に
ブッダの言葉教えてあげたってもね
もう
しっかりしますよ
それでptadになると私は私もやって
くださいよ
罪が
ものすごく大きくなりますよと
嫌な気持ちは直ちに忘れるんだよと
再生するなよ
ということは真理学的に正しいしブッダの
教えても正しいし
そうですかと言ったらその人は
起きた不幸な出来事は
頑張って頑張って
思い出さないようにする
それが思い出すならば一
忙しくするいろんな活動を始めて
これはこの
洗礼食べながらお茶の飲んでテレビ見て
いるからそういうことになるんです
ですごく忙しくなっちゃうと思い出す今が
無くなっちゃうんです
だから
科学的な思ういくらでもありますよはい
とにかくちょっとだけ
だからこの騙すことは人類みんな
多かれ少なからやっているしそこで凶暴な
人々は
起きない意識で人類
騙しているし
例えばクリスマスは何ですか
完璧騙しでしょう
何でずっとこれはやるんですかと
商売やってる人々なんです
いろんな
食うだら
ガラクターを打って1日で終わるし
ボロ儲けしているんです
クリスマスの
25日もう
至る所
ですね
キリスト教の国でもそんなこと言われるん
だけど
コンビニでライブチキン買っていってやる
と
まぁ
ヨーロッパ人の伝統的な
一つのお祭りで
家族一緒になる一緒にご飯食べて
みんなバラバラ別れているんだから一年に
1回だけでも
一緒になって気持ちよく
楽しく正解ゲームやったりいろいろ遊ん
だり
まぁそういう
意味のことだからその意味では悪いこと
じゃないんです
日本でも
条文になってくるとみんな
田舎に実家に戻るでしょうに
それを見せ悪いことじゃないんです
先生親が生きているか死んでいるかも知ら
ないで
覚えになってくるともう田舎にいるんです
それは
良いことでしょうに
それに余計な騙し文句騙してくれ騙し信仰
入れて欲しくない
そこでどこでもやらないんだけど日本では
ハロウィンがあるんですよ
私は旗が大変でしょうその
ただある見たのはこのお父さんがね
息子
自転車に
乗って
すっごい出るんですね
子供が
しっかりあの
スーパーマンのきっと来ているんですね
だからお父さんとしてはあのマント
肩にかけてあれがさ
ふわふわして
死ぬと子供が
気持ちいいんだからそうさせてあげたいん
ですだから早く漕いでいるもんね
そこで
父親が息子を喜ばせたい気持ちすごく尊い
素晴らしい
愛の表現だからそれは
罰とは言えないよ
しかしあのお化けの
顔とかねまぁいろんな魔女の服装といて
女の子たちとかねちょっと何時間あちら
行ったりこっちへ行ったりするけど終わり
と
何のためにやるのかと
もっと
理性的でもっと
何かお忘れないんですかねなんで日本人は
日本人なりになりのお祭り作らないんです
かねまぁお化けを拝むことは日本の伝統で
もありますけどそれはハロウィンじゃない
でしょうに思うでしょうに
あれはちょっとニューバージョン作っ
ちゃえば
お盆でこんな服を着なくちゃいかんやと
こんな食べ物食べなくちゃあかんやと
あれはこれは決めれば
これはこの
商売やってる会社に教えるをやっちゃい
ますよ何のことのコマーシャルでテレビに
お金
出しちゃえばもう日本国民いきなり作るん
です
コマーシャルもそういうことでしょう
品物の良し悪し説明してないんです
有名な人気者の人
があってこれは
持っているだけ
お化粧品のコマーシャルの場合は
化粧しなくたってもすごく
美しい美人の女の子たちをハチャメチャ
プロがいるいろんな
工夫してお化粧
明確してこの
証明に合わせてそれで
取って
品物手で持って二事笑っているんですね
完璧騙しでしょう
それでまぁ
充電若く見えますよとかね
これで女の身体っていうのは簡単でしょう
にちょっとお化粧して
髪型ちょっと変えて
映しちゃえばもう
過半身誰でも
服ですからね
若く見せることは至って簡単です
男たちの身体ではちょっと無理ですけど
それでこの何だらかんだら使えばもう
これぐらい若返りますよと言っちゃうで
ですからねだからどこまで騙す
知能が働いているのかと
それで日常会話から
世界
政治
経済活動まで
騙す法則が機能していますね
政治家が
世界的な政治家が
嘘以外何も言わないでしょう
どんな
国にも
極秘があるはあるわあるわ
私はこのイタリアで
面白くておかしいこと笑っちゃいますけど
日本の防衛省のところ
通ることをたまにあるんですね
そちらの警備の厳しさ
あれ誰から
どういう風を守っているんですかね
我々
我々はなくて皆様日本人から
あいつらは日本語には守るためにいる
でしょうに
実際は国民の税金
すっかり大放題使っちゃって
国民から自分も守るところでくだらんこと
やっている愛するどこで見立ってももう
興味はないしね
それ今度もねものすごい防衛費を高く修理
しているでしょう
何のため
誰か誰を守るため
全て騙しですよ
ただ
武器を使って使って売っているところから
買いなさいこれ言っちゃうと
怯えちゃってはい買いますと
飛行機嫌2台買っちゃうとこちら政権
学んであげなくちゃあかんです
それでどこ行くのかと訓練だけでしょう
それから5年経つとあれは新しいもので
決まったからとこれ買いなさい
で
完璧国民も
世界中人間黙っているでしょう
わかるでしょうに人間人間殺す必要はない
んです
それぐらい理性は人間にあるんですしかし
何で戦争しているんですかね
感情をかけられる
なんで人間そのお金を使って
地球上兵は出るように
みんな豊かにいるように
だから自然環境悪いアップリカのいくつか
の国々とかねもう
子供たち苦労していますけど
ずっとところでも
幸せで
明るく元気で生活できるようにとかね
そうすると
税金払いたくなるでしょう
自分が政権払っているからあのたくさんの
子供たちが助かっているんだと
地球で治療を受けない人間は今いませんよ
とその国が貧乏であってももう他の
金余っている国々がお金出していますから
すごく安く
治療することはできているんだよと
言えるならば
これで
恐ろしい
船かを
ありません何とか名前の
いいですか
どれほどお金かかるのだって
飛行機も
離陸着陸できるんだから
空母はそうそう
そこで
悪循環作っちゃって為替の入れられないし
買っても使う道がないしだったら
誰かを殺しに生きなさいと
だからロシア総連のその問題もこれ意図的
に仏教を
売るために
もう
戦争をかけ立てているんです
だから人とかのこと考えてみてください
もうものすごく
寒い地方でしょうに
ロシア人
何やっているのかと
人殺しに行く
服に食べるものもなくて
チョコレートやら硬いパンとか食いながら
もう人殺しに行く
そういうことでこのもう騙す世界っていう
のはね
あまりにも
ひどいです
はい
ではもうこれは世界の魂のは
取り外せませんねだから最終的答えは
ブッダは
個人に言うんですあなたはあんた平和に
幸せでいてくださいと
身を守る
わかりやすいのは
嘘つかないと言います
だから個人個人で嘘つかないという戒め
守っちゃうと
自分が絶対人を騙させないんです
薄くないことわかりやすいんだけど
それは次の文章で
実践しやすいあれちょっと
皆様にもやりづらい
ですよこの
嘘をつかないと思って
嘘をついてしまうということが
ブッダが間違っていると言いたがっている
んだからわかってますそれは
あんたバカだからなんです
嘘つかない返すを回っているならばその人
の理性が
ジリジリと開発するはずなんです
理性が開発しなかったらバカでしょこれ
ブッダのせいじゃないんです
ブッダはもう人は理性のある人間になって
ほしいんです
だって私はずっと世界のどんなシステムの
紙にまで
食ったこと悪口言うのこの理性あるから
でしょう
だから
列車やったら
騙されませんだけどはい
騙されてあげるということはできます
騙されてあげるんだったら騙されてない
でしょう結局
今はやってないんで前は結構子供たちの
コミュニケーション
結果あったんだからやっぱり
子供たちと色々子供たちの機嫌にとって
あげる場合は
騙されてあげないと
あまり続かないんです
だからそれって別に騙されているわけじゃ
なくて
子供のことをすごい心配しているからこう
いうことでそういうことでねまぁ
自分の
子供が言っていることはこいつは騙す
親は騙されているんではないかとかねバレ
ても
たまにはしょうがないと
という風に
決めることもありますよ
実践しやすいのは理性を優先にして生きる
ことですねで
欲しいものがあっても
感情のどれにならないで
客観的に
合理的に考えるんです
人間だから欲しいものはありますよもう
嫌いなものもありますしかし
感情に乗るなよ
若い男たちはたまりまするでっかい
トラックが欲しくなるんです
森も
すごいでっかいんだから
誰で買っちゃったら最低差異でしょ
あんなのは会社が書くんやって
個人が変わらない
ですからこの一般の方々にも悪い欲しいな
あったらいいなとか色んなことたくさん
ありますよ
でも
こんな服買ったと私はこれでどこに行くの
かと行く場所ないんだからまあいらんやと
別に欲しい気持ち殺す必要はないんです
欲しいんだけど
使い道がないんだからいらん
必要なものを
ダンマの法則に
法則を破らないで
獲得することにしますそれから
必要なものは
我慢する必要もないんです
必要なものを我慢しちゃうと思う人間で
生きられませんだからね
自分に必要なものあったら
教えを
破らないとダンマを破らないで
収入を得て
獲得すればいいでしょう
でブッダはね
合法に得た財産で
不幸になることは最低としての幸せである
と
解かれていますよ
若者がゲーターで唾液には
[音楽]
幸福感じるものは何なのか
予想しちゃったんです
財産あること
それからどんどん収入があって
ずっと入ってくること
殺菌していないこととかね
色々
ですからこの
仏教はもう
欲を捨てなさいとかね
無数客になりやすい立てを
ものすごいバレンと整えて語っているん
です
だから人間が欲しいものある途端
グリセイを
踏みつけちゃって
活動する
一歩もいない騙されるんです
餌になっているんです
医者クオールしたところで自分が餌になっ
ているんです
はい
好きあの心守った方がね
心を守る
心に煩悩感情が
勝手に循環回転しないようにするこの
感情っていうのはずっと
回転するんですよ
回転するたびにエネルギーが
増えるんですあれ
みたい
ダイナモモーターありますね
電気が生まれるでしょう
だから
感情
回転させると感情がどんどんどんどん
どんどん浮力に
強くなる
そうするともう人間で
亡くなっちゃいます
妄想を
極限に制御
管理するならば
魂は
しないし
騙されることも減るんです
妄想制御しましょう
そうすると
自分が絶対人を騙して悪行為しないし
他人に騙されること
騙されて被害者になることもなくなっ
ちゃいます人はエゴイストで自分のこと
しか考えない生き物ですが
一切の生命は平等であること
尊厳は
皆にあることを認めて生きる
人間が本来エゴイストですよでも頑張って
生命は平等ですと
思ったら相当
宗教組織からも騙されません
尊厳があるんだと誰にだって
平等に
何をしてもこの気持ちをベースにします
要するにあの
生命は平等ということあるいは意識しに
ベースにして生きてみましょうということ
なんですねで
ブッダが飾り自費者を実践します
それでこの騙すという恐ろしい最近から
身を守ることはできますこういうのはもう
100%
聞く
ワクチンです
自費者実践するとこの
人類が騙されているのに
それがワクチンです
自費者が
はい
ちょっと
少々の力アップをしてやってみようかなと
思ったんです
今言ったのは
個人で
心理学的なアプローチですね
助け合うという
わかりやすい日本語ですね
仏教では社会学的に生き方を説かれた経典
もあります
能動的な立場で
他を助けること
施し
義務
責任を果たすこと
協力し合う
友人関係築くことなどです
人にそれを教えてあげているんです
魂を助けてくださいよ
孤独をしなさい
自分の義務責任しっかり渡してくださいよ
と
それで一緒でも
すごくお互い理解し合う
友達友人関係作ってくださいと
それで本当にすごく自分には
違う
友人たちがいれば
騙されませんよ
だって気が合っているんだから自分がなん
か騙されかけているように言っちゃうと
向こうはこらやめなさいそんなことはと
言ったりするじゃありませんそういう人々
はよくデータ調べて教えてくれたりします
自分は
自分の能力を生かしていない人は自分の
能力を生かしてないんですちょっと
物で
無気力で
生まれる人は稀です
人間は
結構
自分の
能力持って生まれるんです
これは相当な能力なんです
残念ながら騙されて
騙されて生きているんであって
感情の奴隷でしょう
一人一人が持っているすごい能力
開発できなくなっているんです
恐ろしいことなんです時々人々は自分に何
ができるのかと私に聞くんです
私は知るわけないでしょうに
この人はその能力を生かしてないんです
ですから
特にこの施しということが
物凄く悪意を悪用されているでしょう
こんな悪用される
概念じゃないんですこれは尊い概念なん
です
分かってない
詐欺師たちが人間を騙すこの
施してのは
命が
強力がないと
成り立たない
だから無数の原因の
協力があって
例えば日本の社会やらせて
家族やら友達やらいろんな人が協力して
我々の一に立てば今時間この
講演聞いている時間をたくさんの人々の
協力によって成り立ったんです
そうすると
法則的に
自分も他に協力しなくちゃいけないって
いうことでしょう
協力してもらう俺は何もやらないよと言っ
ちゃうと
アウト
それ言ってるだけ
狂ってごく普遍自然なこと
私に
親孝行するべきですかね
何か何か教えがあるんでしょうかねとかね
考えていくと私はそれ一言で答えられるん
だからどれほど我慢するのかと
パッと答えますよでも相手にもう
消化できないそういう厳しい言葉は
それで
助け
られて生きているんだから
助けることをしてくださいそこでバランス
外にいるそれが施して一単語で
教えたのは覚え覚えてもらいたいからなん
です
単語単純だからといって
冗談じゃないんです
太陽と言っちゃうとすごい
単純な単語でしょう
英語でもっと単純で3
単純にね
でサンと言ったら単純
言葉そうかもしれませんだけど
台風は
冗談じゃないんです
太陽から出てくるあの
ほのかと言いますけどね
あの中に
地球を入れちゃうと一点にしか見えない
ぐらい
すごい膨大な
想像できない問題ね存在なんですだから
施して言った途端
が心配だとだから騙されているんです
それは協力していただいているところに
だから社会に貢献するんです
インチキ組織にお金あげることじゃないん
です
助けることが人間の生き方になるならば
騙し法則は無くなります
法則は
機能的なくなっちゃうんです
例えば現代時代で
宗教に興味はないんです
が
現代人が
自分なりの宗教作っているんです
だから私は私と死にかけていますけどそれ
でも
次の新しい世代の人々の
考えとか
勉強するとなんか今で今だかってなかった
なんか
新しい
宗教観
それは何々教とは言えないんです
で面白いと思いますしね
だから今まで我々は奴隷生きていて
政府に抑えられて
経済活動やっているマンモス会社に潰され
ちゃって
巨大なマンモ宗教に潰されたって
歴史ずっと生きてきた
歴史が初めてというから
破ってほしい
破ることは社会学的に見れば
互い助けましょうよと
そうすると寂しくないよと
神はいらなくなっちゃうよと
しかし施し概念を
詐欺師達が
巧みに使っているんです
あの連中はそれ匠に使っているんですよ
はい次に行きます
まず最終的な
回答
自我とは幻覚です
自我から始めたんだからね
自分という実感は複数の因縁によって
現れる現象です
騙されてますよそちらでも
自分自分と思っているでしょう
あれも騙しなんです
なんか実家なりません自分がいるという
あれがいろんな
原因によって起きた
現象であって錯覚です
これが事実であると
自分自身で発展するならば
自我の錯覚は消えます
どうやってこの
実感が起こるのかと
調べれると
自我の錯覚費いるそれで一切騙し騙される
は
消えてしまいます
悩みも消えてしまいます
自画書がない人は他人を騙しません
自画書がない人を
騙すことも不可能ですだから私は新しい
単語を作っちゃった自画書
あの自称言いたい今ないと思いますよ
根本的に人は無知無名だから
あらゆる煩悩や
問題が
起こるんですだからこの
自分がいるということは持ち無名だから
怒る問題なんです
自分がいるということをすら騙されている
んです
このリセプションに
冗談じゃないんですはい次に行きます
あ終わった
生命は根本的に騙されているんです
偉大なる
魂
生命なら騙されているんだよという話です
はい
政治で宗教
政治制度と宗教は人を支配し管理します
汝は無能である
我が汝を救うという
文句を
駆使して人を支配します
政治家も
宗教かも
全ての人間を
騙して
利益を得ていますだからこのまんま組織が
ハチャメチャ
利益を得ているんです人類を黙って
で
苦労して静止しても変えることはできます
が
信仰から
自由になることは
個人の能力によります
信仰はすごい立ちの悪いんですよ
個人が信仰するんだから
信仰を切ることも個人でやらなくちゃいけ
ないんですしかし
信仰を変えることは
死刑だと
脅す宗教もあります
だからどうしますかね
ヒンドゥーはまぁどんな信仰でもいいんだ
よどんな紙でもいいやと
いくらでも神がいるんだよと
好きな人を選んでいる
好きな金を選んで信仰して
気に入らなかったらどうするんです
罰があったら絶対言わないそれは
優しいんですしかし
昔のリスト教と
現在まではイスラム教信仰を変えちゃうと
殺してやるぞ
殺すんです本当
立証できない
想像論と不滅の魂という2つの概念が
脅し文句ですその脅し文句持ってくるん
です
神は創造したんだよと
そう言われたらだから何
と聞いてくださいよ
頼んでないよと
紙に頼んでないよと私は作ってくださいと
だったらあいつの条件飲みませんよと
書いて金が優しい人だったらいいんだから
と
それが魂が不滅やとだからあなた
死んだら地獄に落ちるんだよとかね
魂は
どこにどうやってあるのとかね
だからそんな
文句持ってきて我々を騙して騙して騙して
続けていきますだからこのこれこのグレイ
リセプションということでこの政治って
いうのは
地球上正義でしょう
地球上あるでしょう
はい
そこで仏教の説明
ゲニービー出身遺伝速報に触れます
人間でそういうものでしょうこの機械
的に見れば
人間と仕組みに
原理写真にあります
それに
世界見えませんよ
色即民速報だけ触れるんです
耳に音の
空気の
振動しか認識できません
下に
物の
味しか認識できませんだからもう世界見え
ませんの
それで6種類の
感覚が起きますこの
感覚を捏造して
認識概念を作ります
だから我々は世界見ていないんです
自分自身で見えたものは美しい花が
難敵エレなのだこれは
〇〇
するんです
人が経験する認識する世界はその人の
捏造の結果です
現実ではありますよ私は私が
作った世界があるんです
その私が作った世界で生きているんです
それがいい世界だったらいいのに
本当に最低の世界なんです
一人一人が作る
自分の世界は
だから英語で言えばユークリエイターが
ある
ところじゃないんです
あなたは世界を救っているんです
その世界は酷いんだったら
知らないそんなこと
あんたで作ったの
だったらこの花見たら
みんな同じ感情を作りませんよ
自分だけの世界作るんです
だから花見えてないんです
自分がいるという
錯覚を
使って
全ての認識経験
を求めますまとめますこれは
元にはなくて
[音楽]
それはまとめますというなんか持て余すと
なっています
我々の
知識世界
全て
自我って錯覚があってそこに
全部
合わせて
一つにするんです
私が小学校に行った私は中学校に行った私
は大学で
〇〇だとかね私は〇〇怪しいことしますと
かねこの私はという言葉必要です
互い違う知識をまとめるために
完璧に無名に騙されているんですから我々
は
完璧に無名に騙されています
だから無名は人じゃなくて耳も自分にある
んだから
自分で自分を黙っている
自分が作った世界で生きている
これ破ってくださいと
仏教のブッダの
メッセージですはい
それで終わりですね
だから最終的に言ったのはこの
え
自分で自分も黙っているところにあって
騙されたくないところじゃないんです
はいありがとうございます
次の時代でもですね
名前リスト
入れたんだけど
最後に見れましたけどね
じゃあ
はい
の時間ですね
今日は
ここの会場
4時半まで一度使えるので
若干
皆さん
質疑応答など
できるかと思います
では
まだ若干時間ございますので
もしよろしければちょっと
会場くらいですけど
すいません
教習していただけましたらマイクを回し
たいと思いますちょっと
会場もう少し明るくなるまでお待ち
ください
ありがとうございます
ご質問ある方
挙手していただきますか
真ん中のベッドの方さっき
後ろの方から先にお伺いしたいと思います
はい
あのYouTubeで
すまださぁ
聞いていて今日は
実際に目の前で話聞けてすごい感動したん
ですけれども
うちの母がね私が生まれたからと
宗教に入っていて
どうもそこが
私の一つの姉の高校の入試で裏口留学を
やったようなんですねで私その
両親の会話を
聞いてしまったんですけど
その時未成年だったんで
家族のその犯罪ですねあの
公立だったので
度合いになるんですねでもそれも私も法律
の知識も特に特になかったんで
聞かなかったことにしてずっと黙っていた
んですけどちょっと
先月人と集まって家族の行った時にその
裏口入学の話が
私がポロッといってしまったんででもう
時効なんですけど
まあ自分の中でその
ずっと黙っていったのが
なんかこのカルトの洗脳だったんじゃない
かって思うんですね
であの小さい時にその宗教の集まりとかに
行って
普通のこと当たり前のことを言うんですよ
ね家族
親を大切にしなさいとかそういうことを
言うんですけどなんかそういう当たり前の
ことの中に何て言うんだろう犯罪を
隠すとかそういう
変な
性能が入ってるような気がするんですよね
でそういう
なんていうか
道徳的な教えの
影に変なものを紛れ込ませるようななんか
そういうものに対する
子供とか
素直な人ってそういうものに住む
その通り受け取るんですけどそこに無自覚
に何か
毒が
紛れ込んでいるというかそういうところ
何か
今頃になって30年たって気づいたって
いうのがなんかその時普通に警察に行っ
てればよかったんですけど
なんて言うんですかねその
彼と
で結構日本に
[音楽]
侵略行為かけてるような感じがするんです
けどそういうものの対策とか何か
アドバイスありましたらお願いします
今
質問された方が
[音楽]
ご実家の方でその前カルト宗教と言われて
いるようなところに入っていて
色々まああったんですけどその
彼女が言うにはその
一見する
家族を財源にしましょうとか一見その道徳
的なことを
言いながらその中にちょっといろいろ
なんかやばい
話を混ぜてくると
そういうものを子供とかだと素直に
受け入れてしまうようなことがあると思う
んだけどそういうことに対する対策をどう
すればいいかということを
気になっております
それがとても
良いポイントでもありますよこの特に過去
宗教組織などは
人を騙す場合は
私たちはあなた方を騙して金を奪う気持ち
できませんけど言うわけないでしょう
特にあの
寂しいほど
美しい言葉
優しい言葉
語る人はいないんです
例えば私は優しい言葉語るんでしょう
言いたいことは言いますよ
で何もイエスの方から一切何も期待してい
ないんですしかし皆様真面目に仏教を実践
して
心の悩みがなくなったら
頑張った甲斐があったという
満足感というか
結果があるというぐらいはありますけど
だから
嘘の報告しないでくださいまぁ
だからちょっと厳しいことも言うしだから
テイラーで仏教に来る人々は10人来ると
もう大体8人ぐらい出て行っちゃいます
からね
椅子経ってもここまで
正直素直で
真剣に頑張ってやっている
そういうことになるのでそれであんた勉強
してほしいのは
詐欺師ほど
優しい言葉語る人間がないんです人間なん
でそんなに昔々
大事にしましょうお前うるさい
ですかね
旦那さんを大事にしましょう
奥様のこと大事にしてくださいと
うるさいでしょうに
皆様根性がないんです
あなたのあなたは自分のお子様達のことを
すごく大事にしてくださいと
お前うるさいやと
そんな
当たり前の
人が
持っている感情
繰り返しリピートするんですそれはもう
体であろうが何であろうか
詐欺師たちの手口なんです
だから私は使いたくない
フレーズがありますけど
使いた来ないのそれは嘘だからなんです
サタンは
聖書を引用して
美しい言葉で語るんだよと
言ってサタンの言うわけに負けるなよと
教会が言っているんです
でもそれも詐欺師なんです
サタンは
本当に良い人なんです
[音楽]
サタンは人間に自由になりなさいと言って
いるんです
ヤフーは
お前ら
奴隷措置
欲しくて最初にもいっぱい奴隷作っちゃっ
たんだから
あいつは人間どれになってほしい
サタンは12年なさいと
だから拝むにはサタンを拝んだ方がいいん
でしょうだから
教会が
直さない
先の言葉で
聖書引用していきましょうサタンはと
いうことは
言葉を美しいと
牧師さんの神父さんの
言葉よりもという話でしょう
そこを使いたくないんです
それも
詐欺の言葉だからしかし
皆様日本で生きているんだから日本の中で
もあまりにも道徳語ってくるとあんまりに
も
あれやこれ言ってくるとちょっと
ヤバイと思う方がいいんじゃないかなと
例えば日本の若者っていうのは
宗教で言った途端なんかちょっと舞台と
いう感じするでしょう
仕方がないんですそれは
だって舞台ところじゃなくて鬼ですから
これで私が
宗教ではないと言っている個性にあなたの
宗教だとこれ被害私が受けなくちゃなん
です
何で私は
詐欺行為やってないのに被害を受けなく
ちゃあんですかね
そこで私は何を負けないんだから
ジャーンと言っちゃいますよ
いくら批判したっても
批判した人に
過ぎませんというしかなくなっちゃうん
です
とにかくそんな個人的な話を置いといて
なんか歳のせいです
この人は洗脳するとき
よく使う手口なんです
その中に脅しがあるし
すごいなんか
実行不可能な
完璧な道徳システムがあるし
だから
仏教でも道徳あるんだけど私は一度足りて
も
完璧に嘘をつかない
守ってください
言ったことがある私の
嘘をつかないから
守るわけないでしょうと
言ったっていうのと
ということは
事実です
私は生まれてからこの方嘘をついたことは
ないやと言ったらそういうほど嘘つきはい
ないんです
だからもう一旦人間になってみてください
人間は
失敗もするし
騙されるし
どんな宗教組織ももう
本当に品の悪い
他の商売できない
人々は集まって
インチキ
商売やっているんです
例えばものすごい大会社で勤めている
優れたエンジニアのような人は
宗教作る
作
とにかくあの騙されたことは
分かったらもう腹が立てしょうがないと
いうこともまああるんだけど
まぁそれはもう過去は取り戻しませんだ
からまあいやとどんなことは
言い合ってことはいいやでもないんだけど
いいですよそんなのはと
でこれから
理性で生きてみますよと
あの若者使っている単語が私はもう
ちょっと
変えて皆様に言いたいんですね若者の宗教
では
危うくなっても私は金であると
でそこは今ちょっといろいろぐちゃぐちゃ
なことになっちゃってだからこの
コンセプション
開いてそこに達しなくちゃ簡単頑張ってい
ますけど
で紙にロールという言葉もあります
使いますね英語ではね
神が我々に奴隷たちに指令するんです
だからこのことを覚えておくと
私の
主人は私である
回して
My回して
という感じで個人の人生では自分で責任
持って物事を判断する人間になった方が
難しいんだけどね我々は遺伝的にいろんな
遍歴ありますよ
もう
乗り越えてみましょう
騙されるのは至ってやりやすい
騙されている間ではずっと気づかないで
から時間経つとバレる
バレたところで
腹が立ったらまた損するのは自分なんです
この騙したシステムじゃないんです
この
なんかはこの
信者さんが
騙されて
文句いただいて信者さんを捨てるんです
自分を直すことは絶対しないんです
の場合もなんともう
話しますよと
説明しますよとこちら二度と来るなよと
これはあなた
みたいな人が来る場所じゃないこれは
神様が住んでる
尊い場所やとかねあんたに
悪魔が
憑依しているんだよと
悪霊と言ってこの
フリーで
文句言う人を
ゴミ捨てするんです
それぐらい
残酷です
そういうことで
自分で自分のことを判断するできるように
とちょっと
物事を勉強してみましょう
適当に答えたかどうかわからんだけど私は
話はあの
哲郎さんに省略して
意味だけ聞いてもらったんだからね私は耳
が悪くてスピーカーの音はちょっと
分別できなくなっているんですはい
以上です
はいありがとうございます申し訳ござい
ます手挙げてらっしゃったと思います
ありがとうございます
今日も
衝撃的な内容で
不本意ですけど私は自分の世界を作っ
たってことですよねあの
話の中で人間は自分の能力を持って生まれ
てきているっていう話だったんですけど
その生かしていないと
生かしきれていないと話だったんですけど
あのなんとなく思うんですけど
能力がある人って
自分の能力には気づかないんじゃないかと
思うんですその人にとって普通のことなの
に
例えばお料理がとっても上手な方っていや
簡単ですよこうやってやればいいんですよ
なんて言うんですけど私からしたらもう
こみちが料理してるのと同じぐらい大変な
ことをやってるんですよねでもそれは得意
な人からしたらとっても普通でだから自分
の能力に気づかないのかなっていうふうに
思ったんですけどいかがでしょうか
よろしくお願いします
だから問題は自分の能力で基準がないこと
でしょう
だから自分の能力のきつくないということ
は人が言うことに乗るということでしょう
人が言ったらあなたは
数学は下手ですから
そうですかわかりました
そういう風に我々はこの
騙されるんです
特に子供たちの世界がよくあること先生
言うんであんたにはこれ能力ない
そのバハも
そうですかと思って
だから
自分でいろんなことを試してみると
何あこれならうまくいくぞということは
あるんです
だからこの私は今日のポイントはこの
人間が持って生まれる能力を
開花しないようにこの詐欺
システムが働いています
騙しシステムが働いています人は
インディペンデンフリーにならないと
みんなフリーと言ったらこの
道徳もない乱暴なわがまま
の人やと勘違いしているんです
それって難しいよ
良し悪し自分で判断しなくちゃあんだから
もの凄い責任があるんです
例えばお母さんの
手を繋がって
どこかに
祝塾に行く子供が
次の日はお母さん忙しいんだからもう
わかっているでしょうあんた一人で行って
くださいというとその日に限ってその子は
それなんですしかし
同時に
責任が多いんです
身を守らなくちゃいけないし
誰かに誘拐されないように
気をつけなくちゃいけないし
飲む電車間違ってはいけないしそれで育休
を間違ってはいけないしねしかし不利
お母さんが手で引っ張ってきては何のこと
を無くて楽ちんですけど
完璧どれ
だからそれ以来人間になるということは
人格
向上なんです
その人は
自分の能力を
生かすんです
そういうことですねはい
ありがとうございますまた
少し時間もございますか
質問ある方挙手していただけますかはい
先ほどの最後の画面で
捏造という言葉と
錯覚という言葉は出てきてるんですけども
日本人的な日本語の感覚から言うと
捏造と錯覚は
明らかに意味が違うんですが
どういう風な
使い分けになっているのか
ということです
日本語的でよろしいんです
捏造
から
錯覚生きるんです
だから何で熱するんですかね
何か
目的私はその単語を学んだのは
誰かあの日本の方が
研究データちょっと捏造しちゃったんです
ね
研究データにして
本人の希望は
自分が大発見した科学者と
威張りたくなっちゃったんでしょう
だから捏造成功したらもう
胸当てどうだい私みたいな科学者という
感じになっちゃうんです
だから
錯覚
捏造の結果として錯覚が起こるんです
すいません
なんていうか
具体的な
申し上げますと今私は長老の横にある
花瓶にですね
花が
私は率直に
綺麗な花が思うとしかしお釈迦
様の
立場からすれば
花に綺麗とか綺麗でないということはない
と私が
[音楽]
綺麗だと思うとその時に
それは錯覚であるというふうに日本
語としてはよくわかるんですが
私が花を綺麗だなということを熱をして
いるというふうに
表現でやっと私はその花は
本当は綺麗でも綺麗ではない
美しいとか涼しくないってことはないと
いうことを
知っていながらですね
インテンショナルに
綺麗だということになっちゃうんですけど
も
だから
先ほどいろんなところで人類は
騙されていると
という
言葉と合わせて考えると人類を騙している
黒幕が他にいるんじゃないかと
思ってしまうんですけども
以前お伺った話ではお釈迦様がご退治の来
ましたでですね最初に悟られたのは12年
であると
無名から
確か始まって
参加
式ですかそれでは妙心そこで6人っていう
のは五感が出てくるわけそこで
触れてその時にもすでに
何か人間を錯覚するようにできていると
いうふうに
ニーだとするとその12人間という
なんていうか体質を持って
人間っていうか生命を
生みこの地球上に生み落とした
瞬間からのその
プレーインストールされていると錯覚の
システムがというふうに思ってしまうん
ですけどもそうなってくると
理屈としてはそれは誰がその人間の12
人間の中にそういう
錯覚のシステムを
インストールしたのかなというふうなこと
ちょっと
魔法をしてしまうんですけれども
車は
心ですね
別に
黒幕は何ですか心ですね
例えばこれ
綺麗でしょうと私は何も言ってない
でしょう
私はそれは錯覚で言ってあなたの心は綺麗
な花と映ったでしょうだから自分の心は
そういう
インプレッション
感情を作っちゃいますよ
だから人は何
言ったっても
自分が
乗らないと騙されないでしょうに
昔私にもある宗教組織の女の人がこの
ランチタイムで時間があるんだから私も外
にいたんですねさっさと
走ってきて
ざっとなんとか
宗教の名前をちょっと控えますけどそう
いう宗教浸透したらどうでしょうかと私は
はい分かりましたそれで浸透すれば何に
なると聞いたんです
もう希望はかないましょうで商売繁盛でき
ますよと私はちょっとと問題ありますよと
かなってほしいと希望は私にないし
商売繁盛は米金もいらんやと
それで私はどうすればいいんですか
帰ったんです
だからその人に
騙されるならば私が
だからこの
ちょっと成り立たないか
を出している
だから何で魚で食うんですかね
魚がそれ食わなかったら
釣り人に
焼き魚食べられないでしょうに
だから
間違い犯したのは魚なんです
それで
下げながら
生きたままで
罪ヤキになるんです
だから
我々どんな人間の心にも熱する
ファンクションがついています
これはプリンスト
だから綺麗という
言語っていうのは経験より
ほんのわずかしく言語の単語ないんだから
みんなキレイキレと一つ単語使っている
だけで
私が綺麗という時の
感覚と
他の人は綺麗という感覚はそれぞれ違うん
ですねそれぐらいは何となく
推測できる
だからこの心というのはこの
自分の
スピードで働かなくなっているんです
いろんなあの
ループ作って
同じところでぐるぐるぐるぐる回転して
いるんですよ
ですから
物を認識するためにはもう
レスをするしかないんです
だからこの仏教の瞑想でこのループを
伸ばしてあげて
で
流れるように
訓練させるんです
そうするとあここで捏造するんだという
ことはわかってくるんです
自分が瞑想したんだと
例えばこの母音は長い時間いたんだから
今見る
見て
法に入ってから見たでしょうその経験二つ
合わせてみてください
ホールに入ってそちらに座って
花瓶見てエアー綺麗な花だなとこれで今
疲れているしね
長い時間いたず今見て
きれいな花が言うんだけど一のキレイと今
のキレて
互い違いますよどうですか
全く同じ気持ち
ファーストインプレッション
私はインテンションなのにそれが綺麗とか
消えてないってことは関係ない
単なる事実であるという
ことを知っていながら
意図的に綺麗に疲れているかとかベースと
して
意図的に綺麗だったというふうな話を
でっち上げているのではないというふうに
自分では思ってるんですけど
ちょっと聞きたら
確かに最初に見たときと稲取は
違う
局面になることはわかるんですがそれでも
私がその花を見て
見てその
花が美しいとか美しくないというお釈迦様
の目から見ればそういうことと無関係に
多々あるだけだと
だから美しいというのは私のDTであると
いうことを知っていながらにもかかわらず
美しいと
インテンションのように
言っているのではないような気もするん
ですけど
綺麗という風に
気持ちが起こるんです
それは別にそれがそんなに
ひどい悪いことじゃなくてあれプログラム
でそう怒る出来事で
in12年のことを教えたんだからねまぁ
だから
感覚が起こるそこでもしょうがない
レーダー
そこが悪いんです
感覚の過ぎかつ愛がする
そこは
切ることはできます
綺麗な花だよだから別に何と
でこれぐらい大きいでっかいダイヤモンド
やと
世界でこれしかないでしょうとこれは
値札は避けられませんねとかね
それだけです
何としてでもこれ盗みたいとか
そこでもう罪を犯してもう
犯罪を買っているんですね
で私はダイヤー見た時は
スリランカで見たことなかったし
日本ではだから
意図的に言ってみたんですいろいろ
ミスとかねデパートとか言ってね
これがダイヤかなるほど大丈夫かそういう
風に見ているんです
これで
値札を見るんですね
これぐらいにかかるんだじゃあどれぐらい
何からとでしょうかとかね
そこで何でダイヤが高いかと何のことは
ない
光が反射してくれるだけ
なんてことかとただ怒りが安心してあの
興行
ダイヤ違いますよ
このトンネル掘る時でもねたくさん大
安かって
トンネルを
石とか何でも
掘っていきますけどねそこは薄々ね
インドシティ
でこのこの
アクセサリーと使う台はもうちょっとした
ことで
割れ
ちゃうしね
まぁそのことでだからあの
割になく
観察することもできるし
で
ある日面白いことを起きたんですあの
女の人が来てそれも
博士
過程で研究していた女の人なんですねまぁ
大学で教えていたんだから私もだから一応
同じ仲間ということで
自分の大学からちょっと休みがあって
東京に来たんですねそこで私は東京案内
することになっちゃって色々案内してそれ
で行くと
デパートなんか通らなくちゃいけない
あんた
ダイヤ見たことないでしょうにと
女の人でしょう
どうせ大学で教えた人だからそんな
アクセサリーは
興味はゼロあの子はあの
経済学者でしたからね
だから見てくださいよと
見たことないんだから見るんだよと
一緒に見るんですそうするとお互いに色々
喋ったりこんな体はこれなんですねとか
これはこれぐらいですね
本人同じ国の2人ですから
言葉も同じでね
店の人は
奥さんに何かいいもの買ってあげて
くださいと
お子さんでも何でもないんで
ただの友達に
それ友達きっかけはうるさい
女だからね
[音楽]
そういうことで
なんとなく出たからね
まあ
だから見せない人の場合は
熱傷で見てほしい
私もこの
女性も捏造ではなくて
客観的に見ていたんですね
重さやらリスペクションはどれぐらいかと
かね
それから
ダイヤあまりにちっちゃいんだからそこは
よく見えるように
つけるいろんな工夫することとか
そういうもの見ていたんです
技術面
まぁそういうことでこの
物語だから食べるものを口に入ったら
まぁ美味しいと感じますよそれは罪じゃ
ないんですああ美味しいと感じるとこれ
遊びなんです何て美味しいですそれは
カツオになっているんです
美味しいよ
そこらは
素直に感じた
熱傷で罪を犯すまで行ってないんです
だから
自衛隊の
ここで
切るんです
お釈迦様それを発見してということ
でしょうねこれ悟りの物語は
はい
ありがとうございます私の話して皆様は
美しいと思ってあかんす罰が当たると思わ
ないでくださいあの
食べ物はまず私は
食べたくないそんなことは間違ったそんな
ことじゃないんです人間だからね
美味しい食べ物も食べたくない台風の人間
にはありますよ
はい
ありがとうございますそうそう時間が
押してきたので
終了したいと思いますが大丈夫でしょうか
はいそれでは
これで終了してます最後の
基盤部分がございますので
こちらの方を表示したいと思います
[音楽]
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しむなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく一切の生命
があるのでありますように
はいどうもありがとうございます
[拍手]